Well,
so there's malevolence that has to be contended with.
And then the other element is that you have to contend with the tragedy of life.
And that's so in the,
in the passion of the Christ did that and that story.
Christ of course encounters Satan and the desert.
And so that's,
and he's tempted there.
And so that's the encounter with evil archetypically speaking.
And then the crucifixion itself is the encounter with the tragedy of life,
right?
It's betrayal and death voluntarily accepted.
And so I understood that that was a symbolic representation of the logos and
that that was the they,
what would you say?
The embodied manifestation of this heroic path that mediated between these two
extremes that was really useful.
Like that was a really useful discovery for me.
And because there was implications to it too,
and,
and profound implications that also seem to work out in relationship to what I
was learning about clinical psychology.
So,
for example,
one of the things you do if you're a clinical psychologist,
as you help people learn to encounter things that they're afraid of in a
controlled manner,
and they get less,
they don't get less afraid,
they get braver.
So you actually act out the process of confrontation with tragedy,
voluntary confrontation with tragedy.
And that's curative.
It doesn't matter if you're exposing them to their past or the present or things
they're worried about in the future.
As long as they decide to do it voluntarily,
they get stronger and better.
So you think,
well,
what's the limit to that?
All the limit is to accept the limitations and catastrophes of your own
mortality voluntarily.
And,
and that's the potentially the proper pathway through life,
or at least it's the least bad pathway through life,
which is something,
you know,
and then I think the same can be said fairly decisively for the willingness to
grapple with,
with malevolence,
uh,
on a personal and individual level,
you know?
And so anyways,
I started to lecture about that and,
and,
and to lay out those ideas more and more clearly over the years as I've been
lecturing.
And that's what I did for TV Ontario.
And I think that that's why the lectures became popular because,
you know,
I'd put some words to ideas that people already knew and could revitalize a
symbolic vocabulary that people had become divorced from.
And,
and that there was a hole in the culture exactly where those ideas needed to be.
And so people found that they were,
well,
people tell me when they come and talk to me,
they said,
well,
when you're talking,
it's like,
I already know what you're saying,
but I don't have the words for it.
It's like,
well,
that's exactly what our marketable story is like is that you all know the story.
You just don't know,
you know it or you know,
at a level that you can't articulate,
but you still recognize it when you see it and you still act it out and you see
it in other people.
But it's really,
really,
really good to have the words.
And that's partly why you should be very careful about what you say and
particularly careful about what you write.